the jurogan experience um you and i have
uh some shared interests
clearly in the world of uh ufos but
i want to talk most people know of you
because of
bigelow aerospace they know that you're
this billionaire
investor and you're a very successful
businessman but you have
a deep fascination with ufos
yeah yeah sure do how did this all get
started
um back when my uh
when i was about three years old which
would be about 1947
and actually of may of that year my
grandparents had a
um very close encounter that was
dramatic
and they were taking a an afternoon
evening drive in the late afternoon up
into the mountains and coming on back
down
to las vegas and they saw
what appeared to be at first an airplane
on fire and
um the object became closer and closer
to them and they pulled off to the side
of the road and
at one point then it filled up the
windshield and they thought they were
going to die
and at the last second it shot off
and and disappeared
and i learned of this story when i was
probably
10 years old and because i was three at
the time
and my mother had told me the story
so i approached my grandfather and he
wouldn't talk about it
now after all these years like seven
years have gone by
because i was intrigued with it and so
into my grandmother
and she only would say a few words but
she wouldn't talk
so i got the story from my mom and
and they had my grandfather had to sit
on the side of the road there in the car
for a while to
recompose himself and
because they thought they were they were
going to die and
and then he finally was able to drive on
back to las vegas
so that was the beginning for me did he
ever describe what
he said it looked like a plane on fire
but like what was the shape of it as it
got closer
i i don't recall any kind of shape that
was that was uh
grandmother described i don't recall
that um
but they just knew it wasn't a plane
they knew it was that's right so that's
crazy so in the family you know in the
family the family
had an event and i lived right next door
to my grandparents
and the family had an event um that kind
of started
things at that date for me other
personal things came later
but for the family that was a big deal
so this was
you said 47 47. and 47 was the time of
the roswell crash 47 was a time there
was a lot of
ufo activity being observed worldwide
and the speculation is that this had to
do with
the nuclear bombs that were dropped on
hiroshima and nagasaki
and all the tests that the united states
had done and russia had done
and that there was a lot of interest in
in obviously in that well actually
russia hadn't dropped any bombs by that
time right
right it was after that but that there
was interest
in our species by extraterrestrials
because they let oh these
crazy [ __ ] are detonating nukes like
let's let's go take a look at them right
well you had uh so-called foo fighters
during the war
these lights that were following uh
bombers
and the tail gunners were the ones that
saw them most often of course
and uh and that happened through through
the war
and then and then of course roswell
before that was
ken arnold right in about june junish
and then in july 8th uh
was roswell and there's a direct uptick
though from the trinity experiments
right
i think i i yeah i i gather my feeling
simply is that without any kind of
other other evidence or proof that that
was a huge stem
stimulus yeah so this was around that
time
then you had heard about this as a part
of you know family discussions right
and so that sort of ignited the fire
initially
yeah and i started asking my friends as
i say when i was about 10
you know have you any any reports in
your family of anything and
and by golly a couple of my close
friends told me
things that they had never told me
before uh
so you know it wasn't that wasn't
and necessarily an exclusive event is
what i'm saying
other people in las vegas had had uh
seen things at close proximity as well
now your relationship to this is
obviously something that you've carried
for so long it's
it's been an obsession of yours for so
long
yeah yeah it started with this but what
what personal experiences
if any have you had well when i was
probably
seven or so seven or eight
um i used to have what i
chalked up all my life to just being
silly dreams
and i had maybe five or six of these
dreams and they
i could never make sense of them and i
would be
laying in bed on my side and a typical
dream
always the same there would be three
short somebody some things in a kind of
monk
uh robe and so i couldn't see any face
couldn't see any appendages
and these three whatevers were standing
there
and they they were not too far from my
eye level as far as
the heights and so forth so these like
child size yeah
yeah and uh so there's nothing in the
i was an avid comic book reader but
there was nothing in the
in the whole genre of comic books that
uh related to that or
movies and we didn't have television las
vegas until 53 or 54
and even after that it was terrible
broadcasting
uh you know at first but so it made no
sense to me
and so over my lifetime i never
mentioned it to anybody including my
wife
you know it's funny how you keep things
uh secret and
uh just kind of for no no good reason um
maybe i would be embarrassed to to talk
about it
but i finally thought well you know
maybe it was just dreams
maybe it was something else and so that
was a first
event personally that i had
at that time in the subject when did you
start to connect the idea of these
tiny people or human-like things with
extraterrestrials
well years later when i
began to start my process as a
researcher
and as a student in the subject
and began to talk with people who were
who made it their business to be experts
in abductions
and uh the more i got into the field
and uh uh sat writing out questions
uh for the researcher for the therapist
who would be asking the questions
and and i'd be sitting there watching
the process and just over time
i thought well you know maybe there was
something more to it
but i'm better off not knowing anything
so i'll just block it off and forget
about it
yeah we talked last night about john
mack a little bit uh the
harvard uh great guy yeah and he
did a lot of these sort of
hypnotic regression sessions with people
where they describe very similar
scenarios
well yeah a multitude of different
situations
the abduction phenomena was was
very proliferate in the population it
seemed like
even we did a survey called the roper
poll
and we repeated it three times so that
the margin of error was really reduced
to like one one and a half percent
and abduction researchers came up with
the ten
questions and uh so
they we distributed that um
uh and
the the conclusion was a fairly
relatively sizable percentage of the
population had some kind of experiences
according to them
according to the researchers and
according to the poll
um i am not qualified to speak to the
accuracy
of whether the questions were that
relevant to the conclusions or not uh
but that's what they said
and uh so and i had in my own research
found people that i put them through
a regression not personally but i found
a hypnotherapist that could do that and
i found a number of people just
here there scattered around uh maybe
somebody in my own staff and uh they
would come up with
with these these stories in these events
one of the criticisms of john mack and
hypnotic regression
in general is that the idea that you can
put
um the idea that you can put a memory
into someone's head
that you could suggest things and you
could create false memories
and this was something that i've read
inc the criticism of his work
that this style of hypnotic regression
and
bringing up these very specific
scenarios to a bunch of different people
you can sort of help create especially
in
people that are easily influenced or
people people that are open to
suggestion
you could put these false memories in
their head and so
you know especially when you're dealing
with something as fantastic
as a ufo or alien abduction or
visitation or something like that oh
that's definitely possible
um there's also something called screen
memory but dealing with the first the
power suggestion that's absolutely true
but my experience was with different
hypnotherapists they went out of their
way
in fact maybe if they did make a
suggestion it was just the opposite
they might say okay you're on board this
craft
you know where's the where's the
lighting coming from is it coming from
the corner
or of the of the room that you're in
well there were no corners they'd be
corrected
right away by the person being
hypnotized and so they went just the
opposite direction
on purpose to make it make suggestions
to maybe coax the person
to come that direction and they wouldn't
do it the person wouldn't do it
now screen memory is different
supposedly if somebody
has a very close encounter with
supposedly somebody that's that's et uh
you leave that that the memory
turns out to be entirely different and
that's put into you
consciously and you recall something
entirely different than what actually
happened
maybe you you saw deer two deer on the
road
or something of that sort or maybe there
were owls or whatever
so that's what's purported
to be catch new episodes of the joe
rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background by using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify
app go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience